merci monsieur le garde des sceaux je
prends acte du fait que pour vous la loi
suffit aujourd'hui pour protéger les
enfants et poursuivre les parents vous
savez mes chers collègues j'observe
depuis quelques années le monde
politique les hommes les femmes y
compris dans leur intimité et leur
difficulté de parents laissez-moi finir
il y a aussi chez nous des enfants
arrêtés placés en garde à vue mis en
examen et condamné nos enfants ne sont
dix meilleurs ni pire que ceux des
autres pour autant je vous invite à
regarder les autres parents avec un peu
plus d'empathie de bienveillance ils
font comme vous comme nous comme ils
peuvent au mieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]